[Music]
George Annan FISA the love couple of the
century and all honestly I am in a
little day what that why does this feel
like the room Act think what you're in
debt I was gonna wait to make this
episode but I want to know what happens
between them so badly in last episode we
found out corker was in depth
unbelievable
who would have thought buying this
insufferable woman a bunch of things for
money it doesn't have would put him in
debt now we get some input from Jorge's
Jorge's how do you say this is word
sister and she's skeptical what how can
you be skeptical she's so pure hearted
what the [ __ ] is she saying
do you work no she's good with pictures
she has they're very provocative very
flashy children for her just move out
here and leave everything behind it is
she doing it for love where is she doing
it because she wants to do you know her
modeling whatever wherever the other
option is whatever it's not for love you
know I just like I know that you have
posted pictures on Facebook and as a
family you know we talk and we're like
okay is she using my brother you know no
no she would never what are you talking
about my except told me she watched my
other persona she was so mad that I
didn't show a lot of the drama that has
been in this I don't know I'm limited to
the clips I have okay
because apparently it's just so crazy
between them I don't know that's the
questions that come out of our mouths
to be fair posting pictures online it
seems like their least issue their
smallest issue at a moment and I want to
get to know you and other sisters down
judge Bernstein Oh little kid CPC shut
up you're evil you're evil incarnate
stupid she's sucking up to sister I
don't like it I understand the family's
concerns about me but every situation is
different I'm gonna show them that it's
not our case
no they just need to watch like one clip
of you online I'm gonna show the where's
that clip would they give me my bag and
my my neck I'm going back with my I'm
gonna show them so nice 90 days how do
you know that this is this is it no it's
not about the 90 days it's more about me
going broke me losing all my money me
going to jail that's right poor Craig
goes to jail
we'll get today connection that we've
had like everything that's happening is
like it's almost like it was meant to be
it was meant to be
her entire what is called demeanors so
their friend around the family see I'm
such a good girl I just like to be here
and I'm just a little poor little
Russian girl in this I'm so lost in this
world I just want the man
with my makeup I think she even punched
him I don't know if it is using my
brother normally I'm really good you
know reading people but she seemed very
cold
normally I'm good at reading people way
you don't have to read anything it's all
I can't use them cran commercial stuff
like that yeah what do you think about
that George how do you feel about that
um I feel like you know whatever she
wants to do I'm I'm here to support her
okay but you know when they industry it
can get a little hard sometimes
are you okay we're doing about what do
you mean like well okay like for
instance like ready to talk but I'm just
being honest man and Pisan wants to
become a model okay and aren't going to
say that she's attractive that she's
beautiful I see it all the time and I
mean what does that make you feel like
because they're gonna be like oh let me
take you to dinner let me do this let me
do that yeah that's not gonna happen
[Music]
what I'm not open to that the issues not
of other guys looking at um piece of
butt other guys trying to interact and
get to Anfisa finally George gets fired
up over something finally thank you it's
been so passing this whole time I mean I
can't hold her as a slave and keep her
in my basement but if there's you know
guys saying like hey let's go out to
dinner and she really goes out to dinner
and there's a freaking problem you know
then she's getting sent back to Russia
and that's where he draws the line B
times where men are gonna try out gates
I guess it's where like you know the
love and the trust you know really has
to play a big part it's good that they
have that foundation at least it's good
that they have love and trust to go on
because they owe George King the
jell-o's we do like we do with
everything we fight and argue it's great
how do they find this couple it's
amazing the show is the greatest
what look so very important to me and
what I know for my photo shoot I think
George is gonna have problem with my
outfit but it's his problem Wow what is
going on that's kind of you know I want
to see more I need to say bar these
clips are so short god damn it all right
we have shocking and FISA things [ __ ]
sister isn't
yeah well that one I know I know I'm 1
atm quick all right I can feel that they
don't really like what you have so many
likable quality George but that was just
some sit down who tells their sister
about their problem what the hell oh my
god I was thinking a lot about their
origin Jorge it's like yeah obviously
what she does that's on her 100% right
but he's also allowing her behavior to
happen you know if unless you put your
foot down in a relationship and say no
I'm not gonna tolerate this or you went
too far it's just gonna keep going and
going and going and she's just going as
far as she can at every time so he is
technically allowing her behavior to
happen by just lighting its lime you
know it's like you have a problem with
something ok I'm putting my foot down
I'm saying no you don't talk to me that
way P you can go back to Russia
otherwise I'm sure I'm sure you can find
someone better to like she's like my
confidante you know like I can like get
experience from a woman like does anyone
like and fees on camera
okay all right all right place your bets
ladies and gentlemen is Jorge going to
stand up for his sister for once go
against his insufferable wife or not I'm
I don't know she just called
what are your sisters yeah they work
Debbie would like a nice car oh my god
you will admit the sisters say you're in
this relationship for the money so they
have a legitimate reason not Jorge you
gettin sent as little son of a [ __ ] oh
my god
no reaction just uh-huh you see you see
what I mean we're what I talked about
before you allow that to happen that's
the time to say no you don't talk good
you don't call my sister that I don't
care what she dig that's not acceptable
BAM you're out boom Bing shouldn't be so
hard you sitting me unbelievable I like
you yeah yes she's like what like what
is it to the fantasies admitting to the
fact that she's here for a green card
and money well then why are you with her
begs to question this today yes
no no because I hope the things would
change yeah well they're not going to
change that's such a stupid Oh
I get so annoyed fiancee try to break up
yes
must watch everything here it comes
[Music]
I think that were you know you're done
in about all an acquittance thank you 90
days is coming to an end so you need to
decide something yeah you know this is
just something that producer set up Oh
ninety and what are they gonna do come
on this is bull they're not gonna do it
god damn it
[Music]
well this is nice nice natural chemistry
and flow conversation mm-hmm yes yes
well I really appreciate you going out
of your way and working this for us
going out of the way those two minutes
hello
make a reservation yes my husband paid
thank you
time to break it up time to call the
quits I know the pressures it's been
crazy
like we have to get married or you have
to go back go back go back go back go
back go back go back
what there's no I love George what I
wanted him to give me more attention I
didn't think I'd be spending so much
time alone here in America I don't think
George realizes that it's really hard
for me and I would like him to be more
supporting and understanding so Martha
told me about an incident he had a
business deal it was like 15 grand on
the line and she just kept calling him
and interrupting his cell phone while he
was trying to make this deal and he's
like can you stop calling me I haven't
seen the clay I can't find me stop
calling me I'm trying to get this job
but we weren't and she's like no there
is no job there is no money and she has
control over his phone because she has
to log into his password so she just
shut down the call while he was doing it
it's like Jesus Christ dude a husband
should provide for family but they
should also spend all the time with them
we need to do now for you and I to be
happy
Paul live acquits break up break up and
call it quits go back to Russia
bye-bye you don't have any thoughts
period it's just hard because
go back bye bye bye bye bye bye bye go
back go back
bye bye what is this music I'm supposed
to feel sad I don't know that's why
you're going
I booked through the flights we're going
right now sometimes I feel like you
don't appreciate what I do for you like
sometimes he became in that because he
was not working enough that was his
[Music]
first time it's in some piece of got
here she's opening up a little bit more
and it feels really good I put myself in
her shoes and I see what the problem is
like do you want this do you want to be
here in America No
[Music]
do you want to marry
say no please he's not gonna break it up
she needs to do it he's too much of a
sim what I want from you is to be a
little bit patient I feel like I need to
change I need to be more calm and more
patient so I'm gonna try to do that
I know sometimes they can be so mean
it's also crazy what what do you think
is the most important in a relationship
Wow
money is not anything to fall in love
then what oh my god
I'm worried that if I lose everything go
broke like would you still love me no of
course
her response with she would still be
with me no matter what yeah of course
yeah so Jen even look how happy is oh my
god you cannot all this weight has been
no he did not buy that is this a joke
[Music]
like I'm gonna try my best to do
whatever I can to be a better man I
can't watch I need another clip honey I
can't watch it
Wow I'm pay so you could tell that
George was really hurt did you regret
itching the word idiot in the car why
not oh yeah she called it an idiot in
the car how long does she take yeah why
not why not a visa windows shut down
windows blue screen oh god she's still
not speaking my god say something
because he is stupid
even this logic herself can't wrap her
head around this oh my god how long this
is an edited meme isn't it there's no
way they took this line treating
somebody that you loved with respect
because I had my reasons
mm-hmm which were
what is happening
oh well that went well I think that was
a good talk nice and productive a lot of
things were said so the latest update
that apparently Jorge went to prison I
read a comment saying and that it was
because he had 130 kilograms of weed in
his car I don't know if that's true but
he did go to prison his whole life yeah
do you think I'm visa stayed around he's
been in jail for two years she don't
need those to make that face she doesn't
need Pringles what a surprise
[Music]
stop trying please Oh what my god can
you sky get what does it take for this
guy to open his denies Jesus oh my god
[Music]
yes thank you yes you are oh my god yes
two years you spent two years that's
what I needed
damn we lost so much weight
sim prehab that's what he needed look
how much happier he sounds there's hope
for the future in this man's Wars that
means he's out now just now the ham TLC
please we want cameras rolling as soon
as he's out chris is here from PETA by
video poor guy I feel so bad for you I
don't think people realize how she
actually ruin his life
kaleil he was busted without a minor we
because he felt pressure to make more
money for her not only lost two years
life but he may likely never be able to
work in the marijuana industry anymore
due to his conviction so the only job he
has ever known it's out of his reach
broke unemployed convicted felon
heartbroken all for a woman with a cruel
heart damn I wish him nothing but the
best and may he prosper in life and find
true love Franco chip a pizza could've
died without she's someone else's
problem what a night man what one woman
can do the sky's the limit
hashtag read them and there he is on the
car and he's posting with his sister
well kind of a strange happy ending I
would say there you have it that's the
in fisa jorge saga my god twists and
turns and there was so much that we
didn't even look up maybe I'll do more
in the future if you enjoy this video
hit the like button subscribe we're
trying to hit a hundred and six million
subs come on gamers can we do I see you
guys tomorrow
Hado
[Music]
it's time to race what was once
forgotten what creatures fought spells
and pull troops awaits booty is coming
to Nintendo's wait and remember it has a
very big peepee pre-order promotion
timing
again we assetbook birthday girl around
the world